buonasera parto subito con una domanda
secondo voi si può ascrivere di cibo
senza scrivere di cibo proviamo a
pensarci c'è un cibo cucinato un cibo
mangiato un cibo coltivato
ma c'è anche un cibo immaginato un cibo
pensato un cibo sognato ecco per me
creatività e anche scrivere di cibo
senza scrivere di cibo
adesso vi racconto una piccola storia
personale io sono nata in un negozio di
generi alimentari fisicamente era la
fine degli anni 70 in un piccolo paesino
nell'appennino romagnolo è una bottega
di quelle piene di colori di sapori e di
profumi di quelle che non ci sono quasi
più di quel negozio io ricordo
interminabili pomeriggi cercando di
farmi passare il tempo ero una bambina
con molta fantasia e mi fu subito chiaro
che quel negozio e tutto quel cibo
potevano essere un gioco avevo
escogitato un passatempo formidabile
chiudevo gli occhi e cercavo di mandare
a memoria in ordine di apparizione tutti
i cibi presenti nello scaffale
se volete posso anche ripeterlo ma non
vi tedierò con con questa cosa e ma in
questo formidabile negozio non c'erano
solo
tantissimi generi alimentari era anche
pieno di generi umani di gente che
veniva continuamente a fare la spesa e
ognuno aveva un modo diverso di farlo
c'è chi arrivava quella lista
chi comprava sempre le stesse cose si
sceglieva ogni giorno qualcosa di nuovo
che si faceva consigliare chi no chi
veniva una volta ogni tanto chi tornava
più e più volte perché aveva dimenticato
qualcosa ecco io osservavo tutte queste
persone e da come facevano la spesa
provavo a immaginarmi quella che poteva
essere la loro vita la loro casa la loro
famiglia
avevo sviluppato questa speciale
immaginazione che mi faceva a vagare con
la fantasia attraverso quel mondo
ecco tutto questo per dire che appunto
ero una bambina con molta fantasia che
guardava al mondo con gli occhi del cibo
e ora sono un'adulta con molta fantasia
che continua a spiegarsi il mondo
attraverso il cibo
oggi mi viene chiesto di parlare di
creatività beh cos'è per me il cibo oggi
oggi non è solo un gioco naturalmente il
cibo per me è un linguaggio universale
che non ha bisogno di traduzioni il cibo
pensateci bene è qualcosa che ti mette
in contatto con te stesso e con gli
altri
il cibo è il più antico ma al tempo
stesso più moderno dei social network
perché basta una tavola apparecchiata
con persone intorno e subito si innesca
una relazione
ecco io ho scelto come materia
espressiva
la scrittura la scrittura di cibo la
scrittura perché per me scrivere è come
avere una bacchetta magica che fa
apparire quello che è dentro di te non
porta fuori quello che è dentro di te
perché per me la creatività che cos'è
per me la creatività vuol dire portare
alla luce qualcosa che abbiamo dentro
qualcosa che è dentro di noi la
creatività vuol dire portare qualcosa di
nuovo nel mondo
tutti noi siamo un serbatoio
inesauribile di idee siamo idee
ambulanti basta solo fermarci un attimo
e provare a cercare no quello che
abbiamo dentro
osservarci serve attenzione serve
ascolto serve intuito serve anche
intuizione la creatività è quando
vediamo per primi una stella cadente la
creatività e quando ci troviamo in un
negozio fare la spesa e troviamo
finalmente quello che stavamo cercando
eccovi provo a fare un esempio legato
alla cucina che così io riesco a
spiegarmi meglio la cucina sicuramente è
una materia creativa no ma secondo voi
quando inizia la creatività in cucina
inizia quando facciamo sfrigolare il
burro nella padella o quando mettiamo la
pentola a bollire con l'acqua
no la creatività inizia prima inizia
quando andiamo a fare la spesa
io ho questa sera per voi ho scritto la
mia lista della spesa creativa
vi ho detto il cibo non ha solo una
dimensione materica e produttiva
il cibo anche una dimensione
sentimentale
collettiva culturale quindi in questa
lista non trovate cibo commestibile
beh come prima cosa comprerei meglio
tardi che mai
la creatività ai suoi tempi
serve tempo e i progetti maturano quando
è il momento giusto
ci vuole a volte un po di coraggio per
vincere quel pizzico di paura che
abbiamo tutti però insomma meglio tardi
che mai
il cardo è un vegetale che matura in
inverno e quindi i progetti creativi
maturano ognuno nel proprio momento poi
penso che comprerei il pensato del
giorno
niente si crea dall'ente la creatività
ha bisogno di esercizio quotidiano gli
antichi romani dicevano nulla di essi ne
linea e vi assicuro non passa un giorno
che io non scrivo qualcosa
l'esercizio quotidiano è quello che ti
permette di mantenere allenato lo
stupore l'imprevedibilità pensiamo
quando andiamo al ristorante e nel menu
troviamo scritto pescato del giorno è
un'incognita non sappiamo cosa sia ma
siamo certi che lo chef e poi può
elaborare qualcosa di delizioso
andiamo avanti certamente comprerei un
po di passata cos'è la passata è
l'esperienza la creatività vuol dire
incamerare il numero più alto possibile
di esperienze anche le più piccole
quelle che sembrano sciocche e inutili
prima o poi torneranno utili come quando
facciamo in estate la passata di
pomodoro mettiamo a bollire facciamo i
vasetti li chiudiamo e li mettiamo nella
dispensa noi non sappiamo se e quando li
useremo però lo facciamo e magari può
succedere che una sera torniamo a casa
tardi non sappiamo cosa mangiare e ci
ricordiamo di quel vasetto di passata
per fare un piatto di pasta andiamo
avanti
quarto ingrediente a ciascuno il sugo
creatività è scegliere una strada
diversa magari quella che non fa nessun
altro e poi farla propria creatività per
me essere autentici che attenzione ho
detto autentici non ho detto originali
perché essere per forza originali non
sempre vuol dire essere autentici ma se
siamo autentici sicuramente saremo
originali come come il sugo no ognuno al
suo il suo che facciamo a casa nostra
sempre un sapore particolare è più buono
quello della mamma e della nonna e
nessuno ne ha il più grande chef sarebbe
in grado di ricrearlo
andiamo avanti
sapete cos dico quando mi chiedono ma
come fare il tuo mestiere tu che vai
delle settimane in giro a provare
ristoranti nuovi che conosci gli chef e
provi assaggi cibo vino e io dico devo
guadagnarmi il cava il caviale
quotidiano
qualcuno deve farlo qualcuno deve
appunto girare l'italia il mondo alla
ricerca delle nuove creatività che ci
sono sul cibo però il lavoro duro e
faticoso
la creatività comporta anche duro lavoro
anche se appunto è cosparso di caviale
andiamo avanti
come
quinto sesto ingrediente direi le cozze
se su un box e si apriranno
la creatività ha dei limiti la
creatività vuole dei limiti proprio dove
c'è un ostacolo da aggirare e o un muro
da scavalcare lì si annida la creatività
e i limiti devono essere abbracciati
perché sono una risorsa
ho detto limiti
ho detto limiti volevo dire mitili cioè
le cozze
mitili è l'anagramma di limiti e le
cozze per essere mangiate devono essere
aperte e ci sono anche tanti modi per
farlo però fateci caso ce n'è sempre
qualcuna che non si apre
un marito o un maritozzo è bella scelta
la creatività è contagiosa quindi
bisogna circondarsi di persone creative
frequentare ambienti creativi perché la
creatività è un'energia che passa di
gente ingente e quindi la creatività ha
bisogno di nutrirsi dell'energia degli
archi pri e della condivisione
andiamo avanti ecco prenderei anche un
po di avocado di me stesso creatività e
difendere le proprie idee essere in
prima linea essere i primi fan di noi
stessi scegliere il proprio progetto
creativo e buttarci dentro tutto il
cuore
non a caso l'avocado ha un cuore molto
grande e poi riso tanto io per me la
creatività
spero abbiate capito che va da questo
intervento è non prendersi troppo sul
serio la creatività e leggerezza e gioco
è sicuramente fatica è duro lavoro però
a me piace alla fine di un progetto dire
abbiamo fatti canto tanto è stato bello
e abbiamo tanto riso dulcis in fundo
qualche cassata e qualche cazzata
bisogna farla creatività è
concedersi anche la possibilità di
sbagliare di provare e riprovare e di
fare appunto qualche qualche cassata e
la cucina in questo caso è un'ottima
metafora e ci viene incontro perché non
tutte le ciambelle riescono col buco
perché a volte il vino sa di tappo però
come diceva giulia child la cucina il
posto dove puoi mangiare i tuoi errori e
non sempre succede nella vita
bene con questa lista della spesa che vi
invito a fare vostra io ho creato nei
miei quasi vent'anni di attività tanti
progetti tanti progetti che qualcuno ha
definito
particolarissimi perché sposo il cibo in
un binomio fantastico come direbbe
gianni rodari lo sposo sempre a qualche
cos'altro
la mia rivista dispensa in cui racconto
le storie di generi alimentari e generi
umani
libri in cui il cibo diventa
un dialogo è qualcosa che tiene insieme
il mondo dell'amicizia
l'atlante di joe gastronomia in cui il
cibo mi serve per ridisegnare dei
confini e limiti geografici dividere il
mondo in spazi q.li ha ri e poi ancora
tanti for our pizza people guida alle
città per appassionati di pizza e poi
fame concreta perché il cibo non è solo
quello che mangiamo ma attenzione
guardiamo dove mangiamo quindi un
progetto dedicato alla ceramica da
tavola provviste per chi va a fare
trekking trekking e cibo e naturalmente
bisogna mangiare anche quando si cammina
vedete quanto è
ricco il mondo del cibo e quanto il cibo
è veramente un linguaggio creativo e poi
innesti dove parliamo di cibo e di
sostenibilità
bene dopo tutte queste parole forse
state pensando che tutto quello che vi
ho detto è
aria fritta e forse avete ragione perché
la creatività non a liszt e la
creatività non ha regole non a manuali e
non a maestri la creatività non si
impara la creatività per me è il mistero
bello che lega le nostre idee al mondo
grazie
[Applauso]